Estos refugiados son sobrevivientes de
naufragios rescatados por la armada
griega se organizan rápidamente y luego
se suben a bordo de un helicóptero de la
fuerza aérea su destino kalamata sur de
Grecia aquí los sobrevivientes son
traídos con el apoyo de la Cruz Roja o
el alto comisionado de las Naciones
Unidas para los refugiados
están muy conmocionados quien no estaría
conmocionado después de experimentar un
naufragio esperamos encontrar más
sobrevivientes
el número de pasajeros que iban a bordo
del barco Aún es incierto según testigos
podrían ser hasta 750
ahora las autoridades griegas
sobrevuelan la zona en búsqueda de otros
sobrevivientes
según la guardia costera el motor del
barco se descompuso durante la madrugada
del 13 al 14 de junio y se hundió en
aguas muy profundas
la mayoría de las víctimas son de Egipto
Pakistán y Siria se cree que el barco
salió de Libia rumbo a Italia tomando
una de las rutas migratorias más
mortíferas del mundo
el gobierno griego Se declaró el luto
nacional
hoy todos están conmocionados incluido
el gobierno el Primer Ministro ha
declarado un luto de tres días en
memoria de las víctimas del trágico
accidente pero también todas las
víctimas de Los contrabandistas sin
escrúpulos que explota la miseria humana
una tragedia que recuerda a otra
ocurrida el pasado mes de febrero un
barco de madera se estrelló contra las
rocas a pocos metros de la costa
italiana alrededor de 100 personas
perdieron la vida incluidos al menos
ocho niños un accidente que aún es
motivo de investigación